you are watching ColdFusion TV
hey everyone how are you doing so I just
wanted to give a short update video
about where I've been basically so
obviously it's been over two weeks and
some upload in my last video and I've
had a couple of emails from people
asking you know where are the videos at
what's going on why you're not uploading
anymore so I'm just going to do this
update video to let you guys know what's
going on and not leave you in the dark
so for the past week and a half I've
actually been over in Melbourne this was
kind of just the wind-down time to visit
some family and friends and I was hoping
to put out a video while I was over
there but that didn't happen so hence
the gap and uploading so now I'm back in
Perth and I'm working on a couple of
videos now I've got some stuff coming up
from Volkswagen Sony virtual reality and
also working on another music mix so
don't worry I'm still around and going
to keep uploading videos thanks for your
patience also the channel has just
crossed 900,000 subscribers so very huge
thank you to every single one of you I
really appreciate it and I also want to
thank my patrons for making this
possible as well and yeah that's
basically it anyway thanks for watching
and I'll see you guys again soon for the
next video cold fusion is me thinking
[Music]
you